horst seehofer unser innenminister hat
als reaktion auf den anschlag von halle
eine wichtige debatte losgetreten wie
gefährlich ist unsere gamer szene
gute frage sherlock horst sag ich da
gute frage ja ich hatte privat und im
stillen gehofft wir könnten nach all den
jahren der sehschwäche rechts endlich
mal tiefer gehen über nazis diskutiert
aber scheinbar haben wir doch ganz
andere sorgen viele von den tätern oder
den potenziellen tätern kommen aus der
gamer szene
manche nehmen sich simulationen geradezu
zum vorbild ja nach dieser profunden
simulation von politik doch mal kurz die
frage ist es klug sämtliche gamer unter
generalverdacht zu stellen meine
verdächtigen wenn ich gleich alle
internet user und führende
vorratsdatenspeicherung ein
achhammer schon gott sei dank gott sei
dank gott sei dank ja ich fürchte unser
horst ist da nicht mehr so ganz auf der
höhe der zeit meint auch abdel karim
[Musik]
horst seehofer ist einer großen sache
auf der spur gewalt in videospielen
gleich gewalt im echten leben
diese simple kausalkette hat man sich
zuletzt in den neunzigern getraut wobei
er hat nicht ganz unrecht viele
rechtsradikale wurden ja nur
rechtsradikal weil sie als kind bei
super mario die ganze zeit nach rechts
gerannt sind
natürlich gibt den chaträumen wäre mein
spieler auch rechtsextreme aber damit
aus denen ein täter wird müssen eben
noch viele andere faktoren
zusammenkommen
was aber stimmt diese ständige online
sein ist nicht gut fürs gehirn ständig
online ständig mails und post schicken
das hat zur folge ein goldfisch ist
aufmerksamer als wir warnen
wissenschaftler jetzt auf gerade mal
acht sekunden bringen wir es der fisch
auf 9
ich weiß goldfisch angeber aber wenn wir
schon über gewaltverherrlichung geräten
wieso findet es dieselbe groko völlig
okay dass unsere bundeswehr jedes jahr
einen eigenen stand auf der gamescom hat
wo jugendliche virtuell mit dem tornado
nach syrien fliegen können hier die
truppe gibt sogar im ego-shooter look
für neue rekruten ich weiß und wären
vergleich denn damit wieder gewalt in
sinnvolle bahnen gelenkt leute man muss
was machen gegen hetze in gamer vor und
keine frage aber hätte ein innenminister
nicht vorher noch ganz andere baustellen
ekelhafte fangesänge beim fußball oder
national befreite zone nicht nur im
osten sondern wie hier in dortmund noch
vor monaten war die kleinste brille der
welt chef vom verfassungsschutz und bis
heute will er hier keine hetzjagd
erkennen aber das liegt vielleicht auch
an der wahnsinnig seinen brille24 1000
rechtsextreme davon 12.000 gewaltbereit
das wird unsere probleme die stockhorst
mal angehen müsste aber was rede ich
hier der einzige der mir es noch zuhört
ist er der goldfisch oder streber
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße